das ist so langsam der absolute wahnsinn
was da um den artikel 13 und die
restlichen regelungen der reform des
europäischen urheberrechts passiert erst
werden wir aktivisten von der marke eu
kommission als mord bezeichnet und jetzt
kommt immer mehr heraus wie hier die
konzern lobbyisten die europapolitik an
der nase herumführt und
instrumentalisiert das ist wirklich
traurig und lässt einen schon zweifeln
dieses video kommt auf diesem kanal weil
er durch die urheberrechtsreform in
besonderem maße betroffen wäre herzlich
willkommen zu klicks um social media ja
dieses video kommt hier auf klicks zum
science fiction weil es das vielleicht
in zukunft so nicht mehr geben wird
unsere videos enthalten nämlich unmengen
an videoausschnitten zitat man fotos die
genau durch die änderung des
europäischen urheberrechts betroffen
wäre denn wenn jemand in eine upload das
gleiche material verwendet und als
seines deklariert dann kann klicks um
seine videos nicht mehr veröffentlichen
youtube müsste sie sperren
zwar behauptet das eu parlament in einem
video dass zitate - persiflagen kritik
und parodie möglich wären doch auf der
anderen seite fordern die neuen regelung
dass portale den upload von
urheberrechtlich geschütztem material
verhindern und vor allem dafür haften
hier der ausschnitt und rufe team online
plattform für content uploads
dieser ausschnitt in diesem video wird
in zukunft dazu führen dass dieses video
gesperrt wird denn er ist ja content des
eu-parlaments ich habe ihn zwar
erlaubterweise als zitat verwendet aber
wie soll das ein portal youtube erkennen
ganz einfach es geht nicht es kann nur
einen upload filter verwenden alles
andere macht keinen sinn und es muss in
restriktiv verwenden ansonsten drohen
hohe zahlungen eine eigentlich verbotene
zensur findet statt für tim berners-lee
dem erfinder des world wide web ist es
ein beispielloser schritt auf dem weg
zur transformation des internets von
einer offenen plattform für austausch
und innovation zu einem instrument für
die automatisierte überwachung
kontrolle seiner nutzer das klingt bei
der eu noch ganz anders und die digital
politiker und politikerinnen in
deutschland selbst die in der cdu halten
es für kompletten schwachsinn warum hier
wird die haftung von den eigentlichen
tätern die das urheberrecht vermeintlich
verletzten könnten auf den technischen
dienstleister zur übertragung der
inhalte übertragen
da wird der boote für den inhalt haftbar
gemacht demnächst haftet dann auch der
satellitenbetreiber astra für das
schlechte programm von rtl oder die
bundesrepublik deutschland für unfälle
auf ihren autobahn oder die post für
erpresserbriefe die mit ihr versendet
werden und so weiter und so fort es
macht also überhaupt keinen sinn einfach
keinen zudem werden die urheberrechte
zum beispiel auf youtube schon umfassend
wahrgenommen
jede musik auf der plattform wird
minutiös registriert und die urheber
bekommen geld bei jedem video werden 50
prozent der einnahmen aus britz hat
einen nicht ganz unverdient denn wer
schon mal versucht hat eine eigene video
plattform zu betreiben ich kann ein
bisschen davon erzählen weiß dass die
technik normalerweise 100 prozent der
einnahmen verschlingen
da können deutsche betreiber ein lied
von singen also wem hilft es zum
beispiel der gema bei ihren klagen gegen
youtube haben die gerichte immer die
rechtsauffassung vertreten dass youtube
eine plattform sei und damit nicht
haftbar mit dem neuen recht kann die
gema nun endlich erfolgreich gegen
youtube klagen manche meinen auch
erpressen und mehr als die 50 prozent
raus drücken ich will hier nicht youtube
oder google verteidigen sie sollen
einfach mal sagen was sie verdienen dann
hat man eine vernünftige
verhandlungsgrundlage aber die haftung
deshalb auf den betreiber der
infrastruktur zu übertragen das ist
einfach ein billiger taschenspielertrick
und es nützt natürlich den großen
medienkonzernen die können sich jetzt
wieder mit den verschiedenen artikeln 11
und 12 sind da auch noch wichtig wieder
als türsteher zwischen die urheber und
die plattform wanzen und abkassieren
denn wir urheber sind eigentlich
zufrieden wir wollen die großzügige
nutzung unserer werke und dafür eine
angemessene vergütung ich kann davon ein
lied singen und habe deshalb oft mit
youtube gesprochen
fast zehn jahre lang und anfang 2017 hat
es endlich gefruchtet qualitativ
hochwertige inhalte werden inzwischen
deutlich besser vergütet
aber die konzerne die großen konzerne
folgen
folgen hier andere ziele sie wollen ein
stück vom kuchen abhaben und sie gehen
dabei unglaublich perfide vor wie die
europa abgeordnete julia rede von den
piraten herausgefunden hat wurde das
jubel video achtung zunächst mal also
das video wurde nicht von europa einst
selbst erstellt sondern das hat das an
einen externen dienstleister gegeben so
weit so gut aber als ich den namen von
dem dienstleister gehört habe da sind
dann hier wirklich die alarmglocken
losgegangen
denn das ist kein unbekannter sondern
eine der aktivsten tätigen
lobbyorganisationen vor der abstimmung
im september
der dienstleister ist die afg die chance
fonds press eine nachrichtenagentur und
als solche erst mal journalistisch
unabhängig aber vor der abstimmung im
september hat die afg eine lobby
kampagne in auftrag gegeben hat dass
15.000 euro ausgegeben und die
abgeordneten mit informationen versorgt
warum diese richtlinie unbedingt kommen
muss von der afb der agence france press
produziert also quasi der dpa
frankreichs der größten
nachrichtenagentur moment die dpa
frankreichs dreht im auftrag des
europäischen parlaments propaganda
videos über richtlinien die noch gar
nicht verabschiedet worden sind wenn die
propaganda machen dürfen wir das schon
lange wir sind hier auch aktivisten und
machen das deutlich während die
eigentlich volksvertreter sind haben sie
wohl schon vergessen also macht mit
programm unabhängiger musiker der hinter
den demos in berlin steht ja sie
angemeldet hat eine super idee macht
fahnen mit dem hashtag plakate und was
auch immer mit dem hashtag no 13
schnappt euch ein plakat ein cartoon ein
papier und schreibt mit großen lettern
hashtag 13 drauf hält das aus dem
fenster und macht ein foto kostet dieses
foto auf instagram youtube facebook
twitter und wenn ihr irgendwo im
stadtbild ein hashtag nur 13 sieht
fotografiert ist und postet es ebenso
wir müssen gegen die kampagnen
dagegenhalten und während man es am
montag ja schon gezeigt als er vor der
cdu zentrale und in anderen städten dazu
demonstriert haben und sie dazu gebracht
haben öffentlich einzuknicken und das
undemokratische vorziehen der abstimmung
vor unsere demo
am 23 märz öffentlich abzusagen deshalb
lasst uns dran bleiben mehr und
aktuellere videos gibt es hier immer auf
einem kanal klicks um social media
darauf klicken da berichte ich über
diese themen und er schaut euch gerne
auch die berichte über das treffen mit
axel voss an und weitere videos bis dann
bleibt dran